[Music]
it's a bit like an addiction you've got
to make something you have to do
something it's borderline obsession and
every bike we build is my favorite bike
at the time and as soon as it's done I
want to build another one
[Music]
spen cycles is something I've been
thinking about ever since I started
cycling my late teens we want bikes that
ultimately you'll really enjoy riding
there's never a bike that's the same
there's always a slight change and as we
built them individually as well they
have the marks or their bike that's
built by hand most people I know psyche
will have an idea of their dream bicycle
and it may be an evolving idea you've
had in your head and we've worked with a
lot of people that have come to us with
sketches and scrapbooks it's really
really nice to build something that's
just one-off and unique I think a lot of
people see a bicycle has two wheels and
a frame in the middle there are a lot of
subtle changes and nuances in design
which can change the riding
characteristics quite dramatically I'm a
really big fan of modernist architecture
and the simplicity of a modernist
building is really hard to achieve and
with some of our bikes they may look
very simple but I think people should
not underestimate the time and effort
that goes into designing a product
[Music]
cubing is key to a bike's feel and ride
Reynolds tubing has been in my life ever
since I can remember
growing up I could never afford a frame
manufactured with their tubing we can
now put a badge on our bikes and
manufacturer Reynolds which is a sort of
thing as a kid I just wouldn't have
believed is going to happen every part
of the bike has a specific tune it's not
Universal the first thing you do is get
the tubes out check they're correct
check the wall thicknesses sand the
edges make sure it's all really clean
because if it's not clean the cheese
won't join together correctly we build
in steel because I still believe it's
one of the best materials to use it's
been used in bikes since the late 1800s
and they're still using it now for a
very good reason it's the flexibility
that we can replace the tube repaint the
bike and you wouldn't know it's damaged
I just like working with it is very
sculptural this isn't sort of aerospace
precision engineering it's a steel roll
and a marker so when we're cutting the
tubes it's within a mill or two but what
we trying to do is take the best from
bicycle building in the past and add a
little bit of modern flair to it
there's various techniques for building
bicycles you do think we'll fill it
braise it where you connect the pipe
together we use a bronze rod and a flame
we heat the tubes up to the same
temperature and we fill the joint with
bronze and it gives a very very sort of
fluid lovely so quite a sculptural feel
it's got a practice you've got to be
able to judge material temperatures
you've got to justly look at it and you
just get a feel for it it's a stage
where your tubes start to look a bit
like a bicycle my father's a jeweler he
it makes or very pretty things it's
lovely but for me they don't really have
any function what I love about bicycles
you can start on a Monday with a box of
tubes you can be riding it by the
weekend and it can last you for the rest
of your life outside of frame on Forks
the other most important part is the
wheels and tires when you build a little
you have to lace them so that the whole
was going all the way around the rim you
poke the spoke through we do build all
our wheels by hand here because a
machine can't get 30 years worth of
wheel building experience color is very
very personal with any of our bikes you
can have a paint in whatever color you
we've matched one to teapot so we can
get that scanned and we can match that
or so on a favorite item of clothing I
like to let the bike sit for four or
five days minimum just so the pain that
have time to cure a little bit and then
we assemble it you get out all the new
components and it's a case of putting
them together some bikes you can
assemble in three hours some will take
three days and we've built bikes that
cost in the 10,000 pound plus mark some
people they're saving up and this is
their bike and they're going to own it
for the rest of their lives so we were
just want to make sure they get the
right thing
[Music]
I think the bike for me was the first
time I had some freedom so as soon as I
had one I was off a lot of people still
get that thrill is when they were a kid
blasting down a hill wind going through
their hair it's fun the everyone has a
favorite jacket or something just makes
them feel good if you've got a bike that
fits well you actually feel part of it
building bicycles as a creative outlet
is fantastic
it's not something you do you're gonna
get a big paycheck at the end of the day
you do it something you have a passion
for it
you